ก็
สวัสดีครับพี่เบียร์มาสวัสดีครับนักเรียน
โอเคสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนครับผมหาวันนี้กลับ
มาเจอกับเพียร์ตีและน้องเดียร์เหลี่ยมนะ
ครับ 5 มาเรียนภาษาไทยกันน้ำกับช่อง
คอมเพรนสะโบวไทยวันนี้ใช่แล้วค่ะเราวัน
นี้เรามาเรียนภาษาไทยกันวันอะไรครับวัน
นี้วันนี้เป็นไว้ครับอ้าวันนี้วันนี้วัน
ศุกร์วันศุกร์นี้วันศุกร์นะวันศุกร์วัน
ที่เท่าไหร่ครับวันนี้ว่าดีเท่าไหร่ 12
ขอวันที่ 12 ใช่ไหมครับหน้านี่วันที่ 25
เป็นวันศุกร์นะวันศุกร์ที่ 12  5 แล้ว
เดือนอายครับอ่ะ
คนเดือนพฤศจิกายนอ๋ออ๋อ
เดือน
พฤศจิกายนของแค
เดือนพฤศจิกายนแล้วปี
คศต.ตะไรครับปีค.ศ
2010  25 ขอ
จะ
14:00 น
48 นาทีเป็นตอนบ่ายใช่ไหมครับใช่
ตอนบ่ายตอนบ่ายมีอ่าพระอาทิตย์ใช่ไหมน้า
นะคะอาจเป็นตอนบ่ายโอเค 2 โมง 48 นาทีอ่ะ
พร้อมไหมครับนักเรียนนักเรียนพร้อมที่จะ
เรียนกันไหมครับเออร้องค่ะพร้อมแล้วอ่ะ
ตี้พร้อมแล้วน้องเรียมเตรียมครอบ
พร้อมแล้วพร้อมแล้วอ่านนักเรียนก็พร้อม
แล้วโอเคห้าวันนี้วันนี้เราเรียนเรื่อง
อะไรกันดีครับ
วันนี้เราเรียนเรื่องโอ้ย
เทพหรอโอ๊ยเจ็บ
R5 เดี๋ยวเราหน้าไปเรียนกันครับไปดูว่า
ทำไมน้องเรียมเจ็บทำไมเจ็บ 5 ใบเรียนกัน
ครับน้าน้านี่ไงอ่ะอ้านี่มีนักเรียนนัก
เรียนน้องเรียมเห็นอะไรเห็นอะไรในรูปนี้
บ้างครับเรียนผู้ชายค่ะอ๋อผู้ชายผู้ชายคน
นี้อ่ะเห็นผู้ชายตายเป็นเป็นเด็กใช่ไหม
ครับเป็นเด็กเล็กรอบเบรคหน้าเด็กตัวเล็กๆ
เด็กผู้ชายโอเคแล้วเห็นเห็นอะไรอีกครับ
เห็นนิจักรยาน
อ๋ออ๋อ
จักรยานนี่
จักรยานขอ kk5 ร้านจักรยานงกเปียตีเห็นมี
กลมกลมตรงนี้นะคะสีดำตรงนี้ตรงนี้เรียก
ว่าอะไรครับคนไทยเรียกอะไรครับเรียกว่า
ล้อรถจักรยาน
ล้อล้อ
จักรยาน
ล้อจักรยานโอ้แต่พี่อาร์ตี้เห็นล้อ
2 ล้อมีหนึ่งร้อ
[เพลง]
และมีล้อหลังล้อมีสองล้อมีร้อนหน้าแล้วก็
มีล้อหลัง
ไงอ๊อด a ว๊าวน้ำนะคะแล้วเด็กผู้ชาย
เขาใส่เสื้อสีอะไรคะอ๋ออ๋อเด็กผู้ชายใส่
เสื้อสีแดงครับ
นายครับพี่ใส่เสื้อสีแดง 5 เป็นเสื้อ
แล้วเสร็จผู้ชายอ๋อเป็นเสื้อแขนยาวถามใช่
เป็นเสื้อแขนยาวนี่นะครับอย่างเราใช้ครับ
เด็กผู้ชายใส่เสื้อแขนยาวสีแดงอ่าแตกพี่
อาร์ตี้ใส่เสื้อแขนสั้นๆแขนสั้นสี
ดำมีดาสาเตรียมเรื่องใส่เสื้อ a  good หอ
ไม่มีแขนไม่มีแขกคนไทยเรียกแขนกุดแขนถ้า
สีชมพูอ่อนสีชมพู
เสื้อแขนกุดสีชมพู
สวย 5 สวยเหรอเฮ้ยโอเค
เออ
แล้วเด็กผู้ชาย
ใส่กางเกง
อะไรคะอ๋ออ๋อเด็กผู้ชายใส่กางเกงขาสั้น
ครับอ๋ออ๋อขาสั้นกางเกงขาสั้นช่ายกางเกง
ขาสั้นต้องครับกางเกงขาสั้นสีอะไรคะอ้า
กางเกงขาสั้นสีน้ำเงินครับ
งู 54 น้ำเงินน่ะ
นี้นะครับมีสีน้ำเงิน
โอเคเป็นสีน้ำเงินไหมประกาของ PHP เป็นสี
น้ำเงินไหมเอา kr สีน้ำเงิน
ka ครับแล้วเรียมก็เห็นเด็กผู้ชาย
ใส่รองเท้าอ๋ออ๋อ
ใส่รองเท้าเด็กผู้ชายใส่รองเท้าใช่ครับ
พี่อาร์ตี้ก็เห็นเด็กผู้ชายใส่รองเท้า
เหมือนกันนี่รองเท้าหมี 5
โรงเรียนเห็นรองเท้าอาเห็นรองเท้าสีอะไร
ครับ
พอดีเยี่ยมเห็นเด็กผู้ชายใส่รองเท้าสี
เหลืองอ๋อ
โอเคเด็กผู้ชายใส่รองเท้าสีเหลืองอ่ะใช่
ครับใส่รองเท้าสีเหลืองปั่นจักรยานนั่ง
ปั่นจักรยานนี้อาเภอปั่นจักรยานเร็วเลย
ไหมครับเร็วมากเร็วอ๋อแล้วน้องเรียมน้อง
เรียมปั่นจักรยานปั่นจักรยานเร็วไหมครับ
เตรียมปั่นจักรยานช้าๆอ๋อประกันช้าๆโอเค
แต่เด็กผู้ชายปั่นจักรยานเร็วมากปั่นเร็ว
ป่านเบลล์นะครับหน้าที่นี้ปั่นจักรยาน
เร็วแล้วเป็นยังไงบ้างครับปั่นจักรยาน
เร็วแล้วเป็นยังไงครับตอนนี้ล้มอาขอ
จักรยาน
ล้มหน่อยครับอ่าจักรยานล้มเออว้าวจักรยาน
ล้มเออเมื่อกี้พี่อาร์ตี้เห็นล้อเห็นร้อน
อ้าเป็นกลมเป็นวงกลมเป็นหัววงค่ะวันนี้
เอ่อแต่ตอนนี้ล้อไม่กลมแล้วไม่กรงจะให้
ไม่กลมแล้วใช่ครับเออ
หรอเบี้ยวขอหอหรอเบี้ยวใช่ครับล้อเบี้ยว
เพราะว่าล้มใช่ไหมครับ / จักรยานล้มน่ะ
เออล้อเบี้ยวว่าแล้วเป็นยังไงบ้างครับ
เด็กผู้ชายเด็กผู้ชายเป็นยังไงบ้างตอนนี้
เด็กผู้ชาย
5 หมู่พญาอ๋ออ๋อจะโอ้โหจมูกแดงได้นี่
จมูกแดงเธอจักรยานล้มเด็กผู้ชายก็ล้มเออ
ล้มหาแล้วจมูกจมูกของเด็กผู้ชายเป็นสีแดง
เป็นสีแดงได้ครับเพราะก็เพราะอะไรครับ
เพราะล้มใช่ไหมลมล้มใช่ล้อล้มว้าวเรารีบ
ก็เห็นเห็นใครเอาเขาผู้ชาย 5 ดวงนี้ใช่
ไหมลองนี้นี่ข่าวเธอเข้าก็เป็นสีแดง
เป็นสีแดงเหมือนที่จมูกจมูกก็เป็นสีแดง
อ๋ออ่าเออ
แต่ว่า
ดีที่เด็กผู้ชายล้มบนสนามหญ้าอ๋ออ๋อสนาม
หญ้าสีเขียวสีเขียวนี้เป็นเป็นสนามหญ้า
ใช่มั้ยอ้าอ้าล้มบนสนามยากเจ็บนิดหน่อย
เจ็บนิดหน่อยได้ครับเออเตรียมเคยอาอ้าล้ม
โว้ล้มบนที่
ก้อนหินๆครับคินขอ
บนหินแจ้งเอามาเทพเจ็บมากจะหนอนล้มบนก้อน
หินเจ็บมากจมูกแดงไหมครับตอนนั้นเตรียม
จมูกไม่แดงเคยแดงอ๋อแต่ว่าเขาเขา
แดงอ๋ออ๋อเข้าแดงเหมือนเด็กผู้ชายก็เขา
แดงจักรยานล้มอ่ะหน้าเด็กล้มหน้าน้อง
เรียมเกาะล้มๆเขาแดงแล้วเป็นยังไงครับ
เจ็บสินี้ครับให้ข่าวเจ็บคอเจ็บ
เจ็บอ้าวเจ็บอ๋อ OK
มีเด็กผู้ชายก็เจ็บเหมือนกันเจ็บจมูกนะ
ครับเจ็บจมูกและเจ็บเข่า
เลิศตอนนี้ยังนอนนอนอยู่บนพื้นนะครับอ้า
ยางเจ็บยังเจ็บๆค่ะ
แล้วก็อ่ะพอดีครับเขาเป็นยังไงครับ
เขายืนขึ้น
5 ยืนขึ้นมาใช่ภาพก่อนหน้านี้เรียงเห็น
เขานอน
อ๋ออ๋อภาคนี้นอนนอนนอน
ๆๆ
แต่ตอนนี้ตอนนี้ไม่นอนแล้วตอนนี้ยุคนอน
ยืนยืน
ยืนขึ้นครับให้ร้อง
ก็เพราะว่าเจ็ดเด้อเจ็บเจ็บที่ไหนมาครับ
อ๋อ
ข่าวนี่เจ็บข่าวเจ็บเข่า 2  2 เข่าเรอะ
นี่เจ็บ 2 เข่าใช่ครับมีข้าวขวาเขาขวานะ
ครับหน้า
ได้แล้วก็เขา
สาย
เจ็บเจ็บ
แล้วก็ร้องไห้มีครับร้องไห้คืนเล่นเห็น
เด็กผู้ชายมีน้ำตาๆๆครับน้ำตาตาลนี่เป็น
น้ำตาร้องไห้น้ำตาหน้า
มันเจ็บมากนะแล้วตอนตอนน้องเรียมล้มน้อง
เรียมร้องไห้แวะครับ
ร้องไห้เฮ้ยๆ
ไหม้ค่ะเรียมไม่ร้องไห้อ๋ออ๋อไม่ร้องไห้ๆ
เรียมแข็งแรงใช่ไหมแข็งแรงเจ็บไข้หน่อย
หรอหรือเจ็บเยอะๆเก็บเยอะเยอะแต่ไม่ร้อง
ไม่ร้องไห้อ๋อโอเคโอเค
ถ้าแต่เด็กผู้ชายก็เจ็บแล้วก็รองได้
ว้าวหากตอนนี้ลุกขึ้นยืนแล้วลุกขึ้นยืน
แล้วไปไหนต่อครับเออ
ลุกขึ้นอยู่แล้วก็ไปหาคุณแม่นี่คุณแม่มา
แล้วมาหาคุณแม่
พ่อคุณแม่ทำอะไรครับ
คุณแม่ Mart ทำแผลอ๋ออ๋อทำออนี่ไงนี่ไง
พี่อาร์ตี้เห็นตรงนี้ตรงนี้มีอะไรสีขาวๆ
ติดอยู่ตรงนี้ครับอ๋อ
พลาสเตอร์ค่ะอ๋ออ๋อเป็นพลาสเตอร์ติดแผล
เป็นพลาสเตอร์ติดแผล
แผลที่หัวเข่าอ่ะติดพลาสเตอร์คุณแม่คุณ
แม่ติดพลาสเตอร์ให้นะครับเกิดๆครับอ๋อแต่
ว่าตอบที่เตรียมเห็นเด็กผู้ชายนั่ง
5 เด็กผู้ชายนั่งอ่ะตอนดีที่ไม่ปั่น
จักรยานแล้วป่านไม่ไหวเจ็บตอนนี้นั่งหน้า
เด็กผู้อีกหนึ่งนั่งอยู่ครับนั่งอยู่บน
อะไรคะพี่อาร์ตี้อ๋ออ๋ออันนี้อันนี้เป็น
เก้าอี้ครับเก้าอี้เหรอเออเป็นเก้าอี้
เก้าอี้สีอะไรคะ
เก้าอี้สีม่วงครับหือหน้าเก้าอี้สีม่วง
เก้าอี้สีม่วงมี 4 ขา
มีสี่ขา
อามิขายอยู่ด้านในตรงโน้นอีกหนึ่งขา 1 ขา
2 ขา 3 ขา 4 ขา 5 แล้วก็เก้าอี้ตัวนี้สี
ม่วง
เด็กผู้ชายนั่งอยู่นั่งอยู่บนเก้าอี้
เก้าอี้สีม่วง
ทรายครับใช่ครับอ่า
แต่น้าตอนนี้คุณแต่
แม่สวมรองเท้าอะไรคะเงียบนี่คุณแม่คุณแม่
สวมรองเท้าแตะครับ
รองเท้าแตะนี่
หือรองเท้าแตกใช้ขับรองเท้าแตะสีอะไรคะ
รองเท้าแตะสีอะไรนะนักเรียนรองเท้าแตะสี
อะไรครับนะฮ่าๆรองเท้าแตะสี
น้ำเงินครับสีน้ำเงินรองเท้าแตะสีน้ำเงิน
เหมือนกางเกงกางเกงสีน้ำเงินรองเท้าแตะสี
น้ำเงินหน้าเหมือนกันเหมือนกันเลยใช่
เหมือนกันสีน้ำเงินเหมือนกัน
ครับมี
ฟ้าป่าวอ่ะคุณแม่ถามคุณแม่ถามว่าอะไรครับ
ถ้าโอเคเตรียมคิดว่าคุณแม่ถามว่า
เจ็บไหมขอขอคุณแม่ถามว่าเจ็บไหม
เด็กผู้ชายเด็กผู้ชายต่อว่าอะไรเค้าเด็ก
ผู้ชาย
เด็กผู้ชายกำลังคิดคิดคิดคิดจะตอบนะจะตอบ
เออคิดว่าเด็กผู้ชาย
ตอบว่า
เสร็จครับๆพี่อาร์ตี้ก็คิดว่าเด็กผู้ชาย
Top ว่าเจ็บเพราะว่าเพราะว่าเด็กผู้ชาย
รองให้เจ็บสาหัสทายได้ครับก็เลยตอบว่า
เจ็บมันเจ็บตรงไหนบ้างครับเจ็บตรงไหนไหน
ครับเจ็บตรงจมูกอ๋ออ๋อเจ็บพี่จมูกเจ็บตรง
จมูกหาแล้วเจ็บตรงไหนอีกครับ
เจ็บหัวเข่าขอเจ็บหัวข่าว 2 ค่า
งั้นตรงนี้เนอะ
ว้าวเจ็บจมูกเจ็บหัวเข่าสองข้างหรอโอเค
เออคุณแม่คุณแม่บอกว่า
เอออย่าขับจักรยานเร็วอีกนะฮ่าๆๆ
อ่านักขับเร็วก็จะล้มหาล้มแล้วก็เจ็บชาย
ครับค่ะเพียบพี่เรียมก็ปั่นจักรยาน
แม่ค้าขอปั่นหาสาวๆล้มไม่เจ็บ 5 ๆให้เขา
โอเคอ้าวันนี้เราปั่นจักรยานการแล้วนัก
เรียนล่ะครับนักเรียนปั่นจักรยานเร็วหรือ
ปั่นจักรยานชาร์จช้าครับหาหาลองพิมพ์
คอมเม้นต์มาบอกพี่อาร์ตี้บอกน้องเรียม
ด้วยนะครับ 5 ว่านักเรียนปั่นจักรยานเร็ว
หรือปั่นช้านะครับใช่ค่ะแล้วนักเรียนเคย
ปั่นจักรยาน
ล้ม
เคยล้มไหมเฮอเยตี้เคยปั่นจักรยาน
ล้มเหมือนกันฮ่าๆๆครับคิดว่า
หลายๆคนเคยปั่นจักรยานล้มๆฮ่าๆ
ทรายขาวมาโอเคอ้าแล้วเดี๋ยวคราวหน้าคราว
หน้าอะเพียงตี้แล้วก็น้องเรียมจะมันเล่า
เรื่องอะไรให้ฟังเดี๋ยวคอยคอยติดตามกัน
ทางช่องคอมพลีเมน swerve ไทยนะครับช่อง
นี้นะครับแล้วเดี๋ยวคราวหน้ากลับมาเจอกัน
ใหม่ครับอ่าค่ะขอบคุณและสวัสดีนะคะสวัสดี
ครับอาสวัสดีครับน้องเรียมอาสวัสดีครับ
นักเรียนหลายบ้างไอ้บายน